I usually don't make this kind of video
but I'm going to make an exception for
today because there are a couple things
I want to talk about first of all I kind
of went to apologize for my extremely
underwhelming upload rate as of recently
it's mainly due to the fact that I've
got exams starting today actually damn
and you know I've had to prepare for
that [ __ ] and also since I will have
exams the next three weeks I'll be
pretty inactive at least the next two
weeks because I've only got philosophy
in the last week and [ __ ] philosophy
anyway and that is why my upload rate
hasn't really been too great as lately
and is it the leak going to be too great
either in the next two weeks but it does
mean that after that I'll have summer
vacation and in the summer vacation I'm
going to do a [ __ ] ton of things because
i'm going to have loads of free time and
if i don't find a job then I don't have
a job so I have been even more free time
which my guess is also a cool thing and
first of all I still get comments about
the let's play Pike whether I'm going to
make a video yes I will do that there
will be a video with loads of operate
and on right stuff the thing is though I
still need to record that entire thing
and I also want to make the music for
its for one because YouTube is still a
[ __ ] and it's still the slave of the
major corporations and I can't use cool
copyrighted music and also you know it
is still cool to have your own music so
why not but of course i also want to
start on a new park because why be stuck
in the past when we can just look to the
future and that's not what i'm trying to
set the next part as long as everything
goes as i kind of want it to go right
now it's just going to be a more
standard park it's not going to be over
the top i'm going to try to be realistic
again or at least somewhat realistic and
you know the themes that I were to go
with are some of the very underused
european themed now the thursday the
first thing I had in mind was Baltic
theme definitely want to try that I'm
also kind of want to try a Romanian
theme as well maybe a finished theme and
perhaps a Dutch / Flemish theme and you
know if I really feel like it i'll throw
in some german as well so that is mainly
going to be the planning for that so
i'll start working on that series as
soon as i can because i am damn [ __ ]
excited for it the rest of the videos
will just continue as whatever I feel
like might start a new city skylines as
it Series I don't even know
probably going to continue their roller
coaster [ __ ] series and whatever else
pops up so that's all about my channel
and I kind of have to head out right now
because I have to take them the vinyls
[ __ ] the Dutch today every dessert